well there will be a lot of fun tonight
on MBC the voice will crown a new
champion ET online sophie scholl AC has
been all over this two night finale and
like Sophie Miley Cyrus has been more of
a spectator than a participant because
she doesn't have a performer in the
finale
Casillas tells ET Miley is getting
plenty of love behind the scenes
courtesy of her man and frequent boys
set visitor Liam Hemsworth just don't
ask her about him our source says Miley
sweet and friendly on set but any Liam
talk is off limits you know it's unclear
Liam will be backstage for tonight's
three-hour finale but there will be
plenty of star power on stage when the
final four contestants do their duet
with some of the biggest names in music
working with John Legend hello listen
listen it's kind of like breathtaking he
doesn't get much practice it's it's him
but you know me and I'm just practicing
constantly constantly and Justin
Bieber's fade Billy Gilman will belt it
out with Kelly Clarkson she just goes
off during rehearsals and you just stand
there and you go my god this is coming
out of this four foot ten girl Stevie
Wonder Bruno Mars the weekend and ariana
grande will also perform the nerves
leading up to the show how are you
handling it
B honestly no nerves what does your
family say to you I don't know they just
cry till they do I guess that's where I
get it from did you ever envision this
night in your head I had absolutely
always thought that I could make it to
the Final Four once you start seeing
things like top ten top
then then you're like oh snap this can
actually happen
[Music]
you